her face is one everyone here recognizes
that's why kahshanna Berger's era avoids
public places she's been fighting for
gay and lesbian rights in Uganda for
more than 16 years but in Britain so
many times I can't count how many times
I've been bitten people have come out
openly on social media and saying if
they get hold of me I went to cut off my
head they're going to put trucks on on
my body and all this so I have to really
really always watch my back uganda is
said to have half a million gays and
lesbians but the figure could well be
higher this group wants to change
people's attitudes with a magazine
called bombastic directed mainly at
tetra sexuals and an annual parade
already in its fourth year they're
getting a lot of help from abroad
supporters of the movement are donating
money to the magazine was at home
they're harassed by the media the very
organizations they depend on to speak up
for them pelting stones to us these are
the people who are pointing fingers
these are people who are sexually
abusing us who are beating us so we need
them to report positive is that we can
minimize these risks in 2014
Ugandan lawmakers made same-sex
relations punishable by life sentences
judges struck down the law under
international pressure more and more
people in the country are coming out
cash in Ibaka Zahra says even if they
still face harsh prison sentences
I'm really really hopeful for their
movement in Uganda because even when
others go at as commendable
but so there is hope there is no doubt
raised hope and the movement is strong
the movement exists and the challenges
are there but we also register some
successes that keep us going naviga
Serra is an ambassador for a new
self-confident gay rights movement in
Uganda it's a struggle that's nowhere
near finished